Я розкажу тобі про обертальний м'яч, але це не м'яч і він не обертається — сьогодні в Qiskit у
класі ми поговоримо про цю квантову властивість, яка називається спін, розглядаючи експеримент, що вперше знайшов докази для
нього. Ласкаво просимо до Qiskit у класі. У цій серії ми використаємо Qiskit, щоб дослідити деякі фундаментальні концепції, які зазвичай
розглядаються у курсах, пов'язаних із квантовими обчисленнями. До кожного відео буде додано інтерактивний модуль,
посилання на який є в описі нижче, тому обов'язково перевір його. Сьогодні ми говоримо про експеримент Штерна–Герлаха 1922 року.
Це один із найвідоміших в історії квантової теорії, адже він так наочно демонструє, як працює квантовий
спін. Але це не те, що Штерн або Герлах мали намір показати. Експеримент був розроблений для перевірки нової квантової моделі
атома — моделі Бора, названої на честь Нільса Бора, який запропонував її у 1913 році. У моделі електрони рухалися навколо
ядра на дискретних орбіталях і могли переходити між цими орбіталями, поглинаючи або випромінюючи
фотони. Кожна орбіталь мала квантований кутовий момент, що був цілим кратним крихітної фундаментальної сталої,
яку назвали h. На початку 1910-х і 20-х років квантова механіка була абсолютно новою — настільки новою,
що її ще навіть не називали квантовою механікою. Тому не всі були переконані у моделі Бора. Фізик
на ім'я Отто Штерн ненавидів її. Він називав модель нісенітницею і навіть погрожував кинути фізику, якщо Бор
виявиться правим. Штерн так прагнув довести хибність моделі, що придумав геніальний спосіб її перевірити і
залучив Вальтера Герлаха допомогти йому спроектувати та провести експеримент. Виявилося, що він не довів хибність Бора — він
довів хибність своїх власних поглядів. Їхній експеримент був настільки простим, а результати настільки разючими, що це фактично поклало край
дискусії: квантова механіка панує на атомному масштабі. Вони не усвідомлювали цього на той час,
але експеримент Штерна і Герлаха також знайшов переконливі докази існування власного спіну електрона — це
нова фундаментальна властивість природи, яка необхідна для пояснення магнетизму, надпровідності та значної частини
хімії. Сьогодні я поясню тобі, як працює експеримент Штерна–Герлаха, що ми класично очікували б побачити
від цього експерименту і що Штерн і Герлах зрештою знайшли. А потім покажу, як ти можеш провести власний експеримент типу Штерна–
Герлаха за допомогою Qiskit і квантового комп'ютера IBM. Основна ідея експерименту Штерна–
Герлаха полягала в тому, щоб знайти спосіб визначити, чи є кутовий момент електрона в атомі квантованим, як
передбачав Бор, чи ні — як вважав Штерн. Вони скористалися тим, що кутовий момент електрона також спричиняє
мале магнітне поле навколо кожного атома, тож можна уявити їх як крихітні стрижневі
магніти. Експеримент виглядав так: була піч, повна атомів срібла,
і магнітне поле з північним і південним полюсами
ось тут. Поле було сильнішим біля верхньої частини і слабшим біля нижньої, тому воно утворювало градієнт, спрямований угору.
Нарешті, в експерименті був екран. Піч нагрівала атоми срібла до випаровування, і потім
вони вилітали з печі, причому орієнтація крихітного стрижневого магніту кожного атома була повністю випадковою. Потім атоми
проходили крізь магнітне поле, де їх відштовхувало вгору або вниз із силою, яка залежала від напрямку
північного полюса кожного атома відносно цього градієнта поля. Потім атоми потрапляли на екран. Штерн і Герлах могли дивитися,
де атоми потрапляли на екран, щоб дізнатися про кутовий момент електронів. Штерн очікував, що атоми
в експерименті поводитимуться так, як я описував досі: як крихітні стрижневі магніти, що підкоряються
законам класичної фізики. Класично ці атомні магніти могли б бути орієнтовані в будь-якому випадковому напрямку, тому, коли
вони рухаються крізь магнітне поле, вони могли б зазнавати різного діапазону сил, що штовхають їх угору або вниз, залежно від цих орієнтацій. Магніт,
спрямований у тому самому напрямку, що й градієнт, зазнавав би великої сили вгору; у протилежному напрямку —
великої сили вниз; а якщо десь посередині — слабшої сили. Якщо атом спрямований
перпендикулярно до градієнта, він не зазнавав би жодної сили і просто продовжував летіти прямо. Через цей
діапазон можливих сил усі атоми мали б потрапляти на екран у різних вертикальних точках. Візерунок, який вони б утворили
на екрані, виглядав би приблизно так. Але це не те, що Штерн і
Герлах побачили. Натомість вони побачили дві повністю окремі плями атомів на екрані, без жодних атомів у
центрі. У них не було правильної теорії на той час, щоб пояснити це, але тепер ми знаємо, що вони побачили це тому,
що кожен електрон має деяку кількість власного кутового моменту у формі спіну, який може приймати тільки
одне з двох значень. На нашій картинці зі стрижневими магнітами це означає, що є лише дві дозволені орієнтації атомних магнітів. Ми називаємо
ці дві орієнтації «спін угору» і «спін вниз». qubit у квантовому комп'ютері
нагадує таку спінову систему, і деякі квантові комп'ютери насправді використовують qubits, виготовлені зі спінових станів електрона.
Отже, ми можемо провести власний експеримент Штерна–Герлаха за допомогою Qiskit і qubits у квантовому комп'ютері IBM. Давай
зіставимо стан «спін угору» електрона зі станом нуль qubit, а стан «спін вниз» — зі станом один
qubit. Коли частинки срібла вилітали з печі, вони мали випадково орієнтовані магнітні моменти. Ми
можемо змоделювати експеримент Штерна–Герлаха, створивши простий квантовий circuit з одним qubit, що починається у стані нуль.
Це називається діаграмою circuit, де верхній дріт — це qubit, а операції, що застосовуються до qubit,
відображаються як рамки на дроті. Рамки RX і RZ — це квантові gate, які
фактично повертають магнітну орієнтацію атома. Ми можемо вибрати тут випадкові значення Theta і F, щоб повернути
qubit на випадкову величину. Це імітує піч, яка випускає атоми з випадковими орієнтаціями спіну. Сіра рамка —
це наше вимірювання. Воно показує нам, чи перебуває qubit у стані нуль або один, і передає це вимірювання на класичний біт —
подвійна лінія, позначена C. Ця частина еквівалентна вимірюванню того, чи є атом у стані «спін угору» або «спін вниз», шляхом перевірки,
на якому місці він потрапляє на екран. Ми можемо використати примітив Qiskit під назвою sampler, щоб запустити експеримент багато разів, кожного разу з
різними випадковими значеннями для Theta і F. Після 100 вибірок ми отримаємо гістограму вимірювань, яка виглядає приблизно так: близько
50% часу qubit вимірюється як нуль і 50% часу — як стан 1. Це той самий результат, що
Штерн і Герлах побачили: завжди або спін угору, або спін вниз, але ніколи нічого між ними. На цьому місці ти, мабуть, думаєш: ну,
звичайно, ми отримали два дискретні результати — ми ж проводили експеримент на цифровому квантовому комп'ютері, який завжди повертає
нуль або один. І це правда, але май на увазі, що вся причина, чому квантові комп'ютери повертають бінарні результати — і, власне,
чому квантові обчислення взагалі працюють — полягає саме в цій квантизації спіну, яку вперше відкрили Штерн і Герлах.
Qubits у квантових комп'ютерах IBM не засновані на спінах, але багато інших квантових комп'ютерів — так. Тому проведення
експерименту Штерна–Герлаха на квантовому комп'ютері дозволяє нам фактично заново відкрити квантизацію спіну.
З 1922 року було проведено незліченну кількість розширень оригінального експерименту Штерна–Герлаха. Ці розширення передбачають
пропускання того самого пучка атомів через кілька апаратів Штерна–Герлаха, щоб побачити, як спіни поводяться в різних
ситуаціях. Ось одна з них: давай пропустимо атоми через один апарат, щоб розділити пучок на два — відповідно пучок зі
спіном угору і пучок зі спіном вниз, — а потім пропустимо кожен із цих пучків через власні окремі
апарати. У Qiskit квантовий circuit, що відповідає цьому експерименту, схожий на попередній, але з двома
вимірюваннями замість одного. Тут ми замінили випадкові повороти, що імітували ефект печі, на
gate під назвою Hadamard, оскільки застосування Hadamard дасть нам ті самі ймовірності вимірювання, що й піч,
але ним значно простіше користуватися. Отже, ми вимірюємо один раз, а потім двічі, і
отримана гістограма вимірювань для експерименту виглядає так, де бітові рядки на осі X відповідають
результатам двох вимірювань. Якщо qubit було виміряно як нуль обидва рази, це відповідає бітовому рядку 00; якщо
спочатку виміряно нуль, потім один — це відповідає 10, і так далі. Схоже, що якщо його виміряно як «спін угору» у
першому експерименті, то і в другому він буде «спін угору». Те саме з атомами зі спіном вниз. Це означає, що в першому експерименті
у нас була рівна ймовірність виміряти «угору» або «вниз», але до другого експерименту результат вже був визначений. Тому
два екрани в кінці кожного з других апаратів Штерна–Герлаха мали б кожен лише одну пляму. На одному екрані були б
всі атоми зі спіном угору, а на іншому — всі атоми зі спіном вниз. Для нашого наступного експерименту давай
почнемо з пучка атомів, що мають виключно спін угору. У реальному фізичному експерименті Штерна–Герлаха це можна зробити, пропустивши
їх через апарат Штерна–Герлаха і заблокувавши пучок, відхилений вниз, щоб усі атоми, відхилені вгору, мали
спін угору. Тепер пропустимо цей пучок через інший апарат Штерна–Герлаха, але цього разу повернемо магніти на 90°, щоб
градієнт поля відхиляв атоми, що рухаються в цьому напрямку, вліво або вправо. Ми побачили б одну пляму, дві
чи щось зовсім інше? Для цього експерименту
запустимо такий circuit у Qiskit. Ми починаємо у стані нуль, оскільки наш пучок атомів у цьому експерименті — всі зі спіном угору.
Потім цей gate Hadamard обмінює координати x і z, так що він має ефект повороту апарата
Штерна–Герлаха. Отже, тепер ми вимірюємо проекцію спіну вліво або вправо, а не вгору або вниз. Тут ми отримуємо
гістограму вимірювань, яка виглядає так. Отже, ми бачимо, що спін вздовж X також може приймати лише два значення,
які ми можемо назвати «спін вліво» і «спін вправо». Тому цей експеримент показує, що якщо ти вимірюєш X-проекцію спіну,
який раніше вимірювався як «спін угору» вздовж Z, він буде «спін вліво» або «вправо» з рівною ймовірністю. Для порівняння
востаннє звернімося до класичного очікування, щоб дійсно підкреслити різницю. Класично, пам'ятай, я
говорив, що якщо крихітний атомний стрижневий магніт спрямований перпендикулярно до градієнта магнітного поля апарата,
сила на цей атом мала б бути нульовою. Він не повинен відхилятися вгору або вниз. У цьому випадку ми просто бачимо одну пляму в
центрі екрана. Натомість ми бачимо дві плями: тобто половина атомів має «спін вліво», а половина — «спін вправо», хоча
раніше вони вимірювалися як «угору». Тож із квантово-механічної точки зору, хоча може бути спокусливо
прирівнювати «спін угору» до вектора, спрямованого вгору, а «спін вниз» — до вектора, спрямованого вниз, це не так просто, як ми бачимо
з останнього експерименту. Щоб дійсно зрозуміти, що тут відбувається, нам потрібно глибше зануритися в теми
квантової суперпозиції та вимірювання — це буде відео для іншого разу. Так само, як ми залишаємося з більшою кількістю
питань про те, як саме працює квантова механіка, так і Штерн із Герлахом — їхній експеримент не пояснив
всього, але він дуже посприяв утвердженню квантової механіки як необхідної для розуміння природного
світу. Це був один із найважливіших фундаментальних експериментів у квантовій механіці, який і довів квантизацію
моменту, і надав докази нової фундаментальної властивості природи, що зветься спін. Щоб по-справжньому зрозуміти
і засвоїти закони квантового світу, фізики на кшталт Штерна і Герлаха мусили брудити руки,
проектуючи експерименти, роблячи передбачення і інколи помиляючись. Справді немає заміни тому, щоб спробувати самому.
Тому якщо хочеш спробувати провести реальні квантові експерименти — переходь до модуля Штерна–Герлаха,
посилання на який є в описі. Дякую за перегляд, і до зустрічі наступного разу!